they thought they'd escaped the worst of
hurricane Harvey in this part of Houston
they were wrong and they released water
from the reservoirs to ease pressure
this is where it came
and suddenly anyone with a boat was a
life so the rise in the water level
caught everyone by surprise Jim Higgins
tried to move what he could upstairs
before abandoning his house and along
what was the street and Joe thought they
could ride it out before accepting the
inevitable people live in these houses
so in fact one couple is back there and
I I don't know if y'all got him out or
not but he there they did not want to
leave they were up in the upper bedroom
and not did not want to leave so I just
hope we can once this all drains off we
can rebuild but I know it's gonna take a
few doors down a family and their pets
were next this had become the only way
out and for all the relief there is
uncertainty and anxiety what is striking
here is that for all of the emergency
services all over Houston saving people
from this flood in this neighborhood it
is the community these people like this
guy with his boat going door-to-door and
saving people because there's no one
else to do
well I feel that you know you should
help your neighbor I feel that it's the
right thing to do I feel that these
people will do the same thing to me I
grew up around here this is a scene
that's been repeated across the city no
one knows how many people may not have
got out it's estimated half a million
will need disaster assistance the rain
is still falling meaning it could well
get worse here many though are at least
safe when they'll return and what
they'll find when they do who knows greg
Milam Sky News Houston